This is 99% Infisible. I'm Roman Mars. For someone who has devoted a good portion of his life telling stories about architecture and design, I haven't given a ton of air time to the stories of individual architects. I tend to gravitate towards the big ideas and the small stories of design
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。对于一个将大半生都奉献给建筑与设计故事的人来说，我并没有花太多时间去讲述个别建筑师的故事。我倾向于关注宏大的理念和设计背后的细枝末节，
and not the achievements of great people. However, some individuals are so remarkable and undeniable, they demand biographical treatment, Frank Lloyd Wright, Paul Revere Williams, Esamu Nguci, and the subject of this episode, Julia Morgan. As a Northern Californian, I am very familiar with Julia Morgan, but many people are not and a new podcast called New Angle Voice from the Beverly Willis Architecture Foundation is here to remedy that by telling the stories of women architects that have been egregiously omitted and overlooked, starting with Julia Morgan. Here to tell us her story is the host of New Angle Voice, Cynthia Crackauer.
而不是伟大人物的成就。然而，有些人是如此杰出且不可忽视，以至于他们值得被立传，比如弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）、保罗·里维尔·威廉姆斯（Paul Revere Williams）、野口勇（Isamu Noguchi），以及本期节目的主角——朱莉娅·摩根（Julia Morgan）。作为北加州人，我对朱莉娅·摩根非常熟悉，但许多人并不了解她。贝弗利·威利斯建筑基金会（Beverly Willis Architecture Foundation）推出了一档名为《新视角之声》（New Angle Voice）的新播客，旨在通过讲述那些被严重遗漏和忽视的女建筑师的故事来弥补这一缺憾，而首位讲述的对象就是朱莉娅·摩根。今天，我们将通过《新视角之声》的主持人辛西娅·克拉考尔（Cynthia Crackauer）来了解她的故事。
The first woman to study architecture at the Aac Col de Baux Art in the 1890s, the first licensed architect in California, with over 700 building designs to her credit. Julia Morgan should need no introduction, but in reality, it is only in the past few decades that her career has received the recognition and celebration it deserves. For years, she was overlooked. Even at her's castle, her most famous work she was overshadowed. With the 20-some years of dedication to building the landmark, often reduced to, oh, some woman designed this place when anyone on tours asked about
她是19世纪90年代第一位在巴黎美术学院（École des Beaux-Arts）学习建筑的女性，也是加州第一位获得执照的建筑师，一生设计了700多座建筑。朱莉娅·摩根理应家喻户晓，但事实上，直到近几十年来，她的职业生涯才获得了应有的认可与赞誉。多年来，她一直被忽视。即使是在她最著名的作品——赫氏古堡（Hearst Castle）中，她的光芒也被掩盖了。她为建造这座地标性建筑倾注了20多年的心血，但当游客询问建筑师时，往往只得到一句：“哦，是个女人设计的。”
the architect. Little was known about her until a few committed historians and architects set out to change that, starting in the 1970s. In this episode, finding Julia Morgan, we hear the story of this pioneering groundbreaking architect, and the equally captivating stories behind those who worked tirelessly to bring her legacy into the light it deserves. I actually architecture at Princeton and I never heard her name until I came out to Berkeley and my brother says, come see the earth's mining building. My brother and sister-in-law forced me to go to her castle.
直到20世纪70年代，几位坚定的历史学家和建筑师开始着手改变这一现状，人们才对她有了更多了解。在本期节目《寻找朱莉娅·摩根》中，我们将聆听这位开创性建筑师的故事，以及那些为让她的遗产重见天日而孜孜不倦努力的人们背后同样引人入胜的故事。我曾在普林斯顿大学学习建筑，直到来到伯克利，我哥哥对我说：“来看看地球科学大楼（Earth Sciences Building）吧。”我哥哥和嫂子还强迫我去了她的古堡。
You have to go to her castle. I thought, oh, this is going to be horrible pastiche, mishmash of stuff thrown together. When I got down there, I was completely delighted. The first time I heard her name was when I went on a tour of the castle. That was in 1976. Even though I had grown up around her buildings, what they said when we were on the tour, they said a woman built her castle but we don't know anything about her. It was astonishing.
“你一定要去她的古堡看看。”我当时想，哦，那肯定是个糟糕的拼凑品，一堆乱七八糟的东西堆在一起。但当我真正到达那里时，我感到无比惊喜。我第一次听到她的名字是在参观古堡的时候，那是在1976年。尽管我是在她的建筑周围长大的，但导游当时说：“是一位女性建造了这座古堡，但我们对她一无所知。”这太令人震惊了。
That was just too tantalizing a problem. It was at that point that I left my freshman composition students after the end of the quarter and started to work at Hearst Castle. I never dreamed that the story of her life would be as inspiring as it is, and I've studied her for 30 years. I'm Victoria Castner. I was for many decades the official historian at Hearst Castle. I've written three books on the history of Hearst Castle and I'm coming out with the first
这个问题实在太诱人了。就在那时，我在学期结束后离开了我的大一写作课学生，开始在赫氏古堡工作。我从未想过她的人生故事会如此鼓舞人心，我研究她已经30年了。我是维多利亚·卡斯特纳（Victoria Kastner）。几十年来，我一直担任赫氏古堡的官方历史学家。我写过三本关于赫氏古堡历史的书，现在我即将出版第一本
personal biography of Julia Morgan. It's titled, Julia Morgan an intimate biography of the Trailblazing Architect. In 2018, an editor at the New York Times emailed asking me if I wanted to write an obituary of Julia Morgan, whom he referred to as the Hurst Castle Architect. I wrote back immediately and said I would love to. I'd actually checked on some other female architects to see if the Times had covered their deaths, but it never occurred to me to check on Morgan. I'm Alexandra Lang, I'm a design critic, and I wrote the overlooked obituary for Julia Morgan in the New York Times.
朱莉娅·摩根的个人传记。书名是《朱莉娅·摩根：这位开创性建筑师的亲密传记》。2018年，《纽约时报》的一位编辑发邮件问我是否愿意为朱莉娅·摩根写一篇讣告，他称她为“赫氏古堡建筑师”。我立即回复说我很乐意。其实我之前查过其他女建筑师，看看《纽约时报》是否报道过她们的去世，但我从未想过要查摩根。我是亚历山德拉·朗（Alexandra Lange），我是一名设计评论家，我为《纽约时报》撰写了朱莉娅·摩根的“被忽视的讣告”系列。
The Overlook series was initiated by the paper because they realized that their obituary section, like much of published American history, skewed very white and very male. There were a lot of people overlooked the first time through with Julia Morgan serving as an amazing example of that. There's a big burden placed on Julia Morgan to be absolutely everything, because she was the first in so many things. I'm Karen McNeil. I'm a historian and long-time scholar of Julia Morgan. Julia Morgan graduated with a degree in civil engineering in 1894 from UC Berkeley. And that was the closest she could come to any sort of architectural training in California. Around the time she graduated from Berkeley, she met Bernard Maybeck.
“被忽视”（Overlooked）系列是由该报发起的，因为他们意识到他们的讣告版面和许多已出版的美国历史一样，过于偏向白人和男性。有很多人的贡献在第一次被记录时被忽视了，朱莉娅·摩根就是一个绝佳的例子。朱莉娅·摩根肩负着巨大的重担，因为她是许多领域的先行者。我是凯伦·麦克尼尔（Karen McNeil）。我是一名历史学家，也是朱莉娅·摩根的长期研究学者。朱莉娅·摩根于1894年从加州大学伯克利分校获得土木工程学位。在当时的加州，这已是她能接触到的最接近建筑学的训练了。在伯克利毕业前后，她遇到了伯纳德·梅贝克（Bernard Maybeck）。
He was a charismatic character. He'd studied at the A. Colébozar. He wore capes and was vegetarian, very bohemian character. He taught the first architecture courses at Berkeley beginning in the fall of 1894, just after Morgan graduated. And he invited her to join a group of young men to seminars at his home. And basically all of them went off to Paris to study at the Ecote Bozar, which at the time was the most important architectural school in the world. Bernard Maybeck encouraged her to go to Paris,
他是一个极具魅力的人。他曾在巴黎美术学院学习。他披着斗篷，是个素食主义者，非常有波西米亚风格。1894年秋天，也就是摩根毕业后不久，他在伯克利教授了第一批建筑课程。他邀请摩根加入一群年轻人的行列，参加他家里的研讨会。基本上他们后来都去了巴黎，进入巴黎美术学院学习，那是当时世界上最重要的建筑学院。伯纳德·梅贝克鼓励她去巴黎，
and she arrived there in June of 1896. This was weeks after the faculty had decided, yes, women, you may attend classes at the A-Cole. That decision came about because a group of women unionized. It was the union of women painters and sculptors, and they fought a seven-year battle against the A-Cole just for the right to take courses. So Morgan landed in Paris right when the doors opened. She got to know these women, and they very much supported her. They kept organizing, they kept pressuring the faculty to allow women to take entrance
她于1896年6月抵达那里。就在几周前，学院教职员刚刚决定：是的，女性可以进入巴黎美术学院上课。这个决定是因为一群女性联合起来了。那是女性画家和雕塑家工会，她们与学院进行了长达七年的斗争，只为争取上课的权利。所以摩根到达巴黎时，正值大门敞开之际。她结识了这些女性，她们非常支持她。她们不断组织起来，不断向教职员施压，要求允许女性参加入学
examinations. And finally, the faculty said, okay, ladies, you can take the entrance examinations. Her first opportunity was in July, only five weeks after the examinations had been opened to women. She was actually a figure of fascination. Just as she was taking the exams, and it was already in the papers, this young American woman wanted to pursue architecture, or how bizarre was that.
考试。最终，教职员说：“好吧，女士们，你们可以参加入学考试了。”她第一次机会是在7月，距离考试向女性开放仅过了五周。她实际上成了一个令人着迷的人物。就在她参加考试时，报纸上已经刊登了消息：这位年轻的美国女性想要从事建筑业，这简直太不可思议了。
Long story short, she failed, but she took that in stride. Everybody failed at least once. These entrance examinations, especially for architecture, were extraordinarily difficult. In October of 1898, she took the examinations for a fourth time. She was 13,000, almost 400 applicants. So now she's 27 years old, and she had until the age of 30 to accomplish whatever she was going to accomplish. On a rainy day, she would sit inside a church and sketch.
长话短说，她失败了，但她泰然处之。每个人至少都失败过一次。这些入学考试，尤其是建筑专业的，难度极大。1898年10月，她第四次参加考试。当时有13400名申请者。那时她已经27岁了，她必须在30岁之前完成她想要完成的一切。在下雨天，她会坐在教堂里写生。
On the weekends, she would travel, pay attention to form. The relationship of buildings, the relationship of light and space and color, and she just got better and better. I'm Julia Donahoe, I'm an architect and an attorney and general contractor, and I served on the National Board of the American Institute of Architects. I was in a position to nominate architects for the Gold Medal in Architecture, and that's how I got involved with Julie Morgan. Morgan met Phoebe Hurst in Paris when Phoebe was visiting Paris to meet all these architects who were competing to design the new campus for the University of California.
周末，她会去旅行，关注建筑形式。建筑之间的关系，光线、空间和色彩的关系，她进步得越来越快。我是朱莉娅·多纳霍（Julia Donahoe），我是一名建筑师、律师和总承包商，曾在美国建筑师协会（AIA）国家董事会任职。我当时有权提名建筑师角逐建筑金奖，这就是我与朱莉娅·摩根结缘的方式。摩根在巴黎遇到了菲比·赫斯特（Phoebe Hearst），当时菲比正在巴黎会见所有竞标加州大学新校区设计的建筑师。
the University of California. Phoebe took a shine to Morgan and when she came back to California, Phoebe was ready to employ Morgan and she hired her to remodel her estate out in Plezanson, which is east of San Francisco, and that project went on for years. They must have gotten on like a house on fire. I mean they just had this enduring working relationship. We were looking at now as the bell tower which was built in 1904 and then around the oval from that is the Margaret Carnegie Library built in 1906. So to the left of the door it says designed by architect Julia Morgan dedicated by Susan T. Mills April 14th 1904 and then on the other side it says, designed by architect Julia Morgan, dedicated by Susan T. Mills, April 14, 1904. And then on the other side, it says, El Campanille is the first concrete reinforced structure built west of the Mississippi. Having a clock on a tower seems pretty mundane now, but back then, that was kind of a big deal. It was kind of like the iPhone of its day. Very futuristic forward looking thing
菲比很欣赏摩根。当她回到加州时，菲比准备聘用摩根，并雇佣她去改造她在普莱森顿（Pleasanton）的庄园，那个项目持续了好几年。她们一定是一见如故。我的意思是，她们有着持久的合作关系。我们现在看到的是1904年建造的钟楼，绕过椭圆形广场，是1906年建造的玛格丽特·卡内基图书馆（Margaret Carnegie Library）。门左侧写着：“由建筑师朱莉娅·摩根设计，苏珊·T·米尔斯（Susan T. Mills）于1904年4月14日揭幕。”另一侧也写着同样的内容。钟楼是密西西比河以西建造的第一座钢筋混凝土结构建筑。在塔楼上装个时钟现在看起来很普通，但在当时，这可是件大事。就像当年的iPhone一样，是非常具有未来感和前瞻性的东西。
that we would have a bell tower with a clock. I'm Karen Feney. I'm the current director of facilities in the campus architect. And we are about to take a tour of Joy Morgan's five remaining buildings on campus. Morgan had suffered through a lot of professional abuse during the construction of the campaniel. She was in this battle of wills and egos with the builder, a guy named Bernard Ransom.
我们竟然会有一座带时钟的钟楼。我是凯伦·费尼（Karen Feney）。我是现任设施主管和校园建筑师。我们即将参观朱莉娅·摩根在校园里留下的五座建筑。摩根在钟楼建造期间遭受了许多职业上的欺凌。她当时正与建筑商伯纳德·兰瑟姆（Bernard Ransom）进行一场意志和自尊的较量。
His father was the leading patent inventor, reinforced concrete guru in the United States. And so then Bernard Ransom saw himself as sort of the heir apparent. He did not like working for this young woman who wanted to call herself an architect. He had gotten top billing at the ceremonies at the unveiling of the Campanille. There's this whole drama behind it. The 1906 earthquake and fires decimated San Francisco, as well as damaged significant portions of surrounding areas. One structure that did not fall and was not damaged in any way was the Campanille at Mills College. When the Campanille survived the earthquake without a scratch, it wasn't ransom who was
他的父亲是美国领先的专利发明家和钢筋混凝土大师。因此，伯纳德·兰瑟姆自认为是理所当然的继承人。他不喜欢为一个自称是建筑师的年轻女性工作。在钟楼揭幕仪式上，他抢占了头条。这背后有一整出戏。1906年的地震和火灾摧毁了旧金山，并损坏了周边地区的大部分建筑。唯一没有倒塌且未受任何损坏的建筑，就是米尔斯学院（Mills College）的钟楼。当钟楼在地震中毫发无损地幸存下来时，人们记住的不是兰瑟姆，
remembered. It was Morgan. So Julian Morgan's daring, reinforced concreteanille, at Mills College survived. Reinforce concrete had been something a source of debate. It was mostly associated with industrial infrastructure really at the time, but Morgan saw the potential for beauty in it because of its infinite elasticity. Steel does well in tension and the concrete does well in compression. And so the two together make a really strong bond and concrete gets
而是摩根。所以，朱莉娅·摩根在米尔斯学院大胆设计的钢筋混凝土钟楼幸存了下来。钢筋混凝土在当时是一个争论的焦点。它在当时主要与工业基础设施联系在一起，但摩根看到了它因其无限的弹性而具有的美学潜力。钢材抗拉性能好，混凝土抗压性能好。两者结合在一起形成了非常牢固的结合，而且混凝土会随着时间的推移变得
stronger as it ages. It's still performed remarkably well and then they would pour the concrete in what they call the lip. When she designed the Campanille, she was really breaking some boundaries, so many architects who had been hesitant in using reinforced concrete for pretty buildings, they went to Mills College, it became like this laboratory to understand how reinforced concrete could be used. That then really catapulted Julian Morgan's reputation. This is not just a novelty act. Julian Morgan is a serious architect and engineer
越来越坚固。它的表现依然非常出色。当时他们会把混凝土浇筑在所谓的“唇”里。当她设计钟楼时，她确实打破了一些界限。许多对在漂亮建筑中使用钢筋混凝土持犹豫态度的建筑师，都去了米尔斯学院，那里成了理解钢筋混凝土如何使用的实验室。这确实让朱莉娅·摩根的声誉大增。这不仅仅是一个新奇的尝试。朱莉娅·摩根是一位严肃的建筑师和工程师，
who designs not just pretty buildings, but buildings that will last for generations and an architect who experiments with the most modern construction technologies to achieve these buildings. She lost her career and shortly after she lost her career, the earthquake happened. The city first fell down and then burned up. 400,000 people were homeless. Something like 30,000 buildings were destroyed.
她设计的不仅是漂亮的建筑，而且是能传承几代的建筑，她还是一位尝试使用最现代施工技术来实现这些建筑的建筑师。她失去了职业生涯，而在她失去职业生涯后不久，地震就发生了。城市先是倒塌，然后被烧毁。40万人无家可归。大约3万座建筑被毁。
The fire took off through the whole city. They said it was like Pompeii. Jolody Morgan was determined to bring it back. There was lots of good work for architects afterwards. In Julia, redesigned, re-engineered. The Fremont Hotel had been a brand new building and been open for a month or something before the earthquake. The whole world was in ruins, and she was the only one who knew
大火席卷了整个城市。人们说这就像庞贝古城。朱莉娅·摩根决心重建它。地震后，建筑师们有很多工作要做。朱莉娅重新设计、重新规划。费尔蒙特酒店（Fairmont Hotel）在地震前刚开业一个月左右。整个世界都成了废墟，而她是唯一一个了解
anything about reinforced concrete. They tried to bring some east coast architects who might know reinforcing but the guy who was supposed to come got killed in a duel. So then they saw the mills college tower sitting there and they were like wow you know that's reinforced concrete and it didn't fall down. She told all of San Francisco, we can rebuild the city. She rebuilt the Fairmont in one year and they had the biggest party. A lot of times I compare her to Frank Lloyd Wright. Frank Lloyd Wright didn't understand reinforced concrete. If you go to falling water, everything looks like it's made out of clay because it's sagging. Concrete is not supposed to sag. Julia Morgan's concrete does not sag.
钢筋混凝土的人。他们试图找一些可能了解钢筋加固的东海岸建筑师，但那个本该来的人在决斗中丧生了。于是他们看到了米尔斯学院的塔楼，他们心想：“哇，那是钢筋混凝土，而且它没有倒塌。”她告诉整个旧金山：“我们可以重建这座城市。”她用一年时间重建了费尔蒙特酒店，他们举办了盛大的派对。很多时候我把她和弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特相比。赖特不懂钢筋混凝土。如果你去流水别墅（Fallingwater），一切看起来都像是用粘土做的，因为它在下垂。混凝土不应该下垂。朱莉娅·摩根的混凝土不会下垂。
Frank Lloyd Wright's concrete sags, because he didn't really understand the engineering, but not hers. Hers is very strong and true to this day. A lot of her buildings are still standing because she really was an engineer she knew what she was doing. When W. R. Perst approached her after he received his inheritance,
弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的混凝土会下垂，因为他并不真正了解工程学，但她的不会。她的建筑至今依然坚固且精准。她的许多建筑至今仍屹立不倒，因为她确实是一位工程师，她知道自己在做什么。当W·R·赫斯特（W.R. Hearst）在继承遗产后找到她时，
which was in the spring of 1919. She knew him well and she knew the kind of client he was. She knew that he was gonna be involved in absolutely every decision and want to know about every little detail because he loved it. And so when he explained to her that he was tired of camping in tents and thought he was getting a little old for that and he was thinking of building a little something.
那是在1919年春天。她很了解他，也知道他是什么样的客户。她知道他会参与每一个决定，并想了解每一个小细节，因为他热爱这些。所以当他向她解释说，他厌倦了住在帐篷里，觉得年纪大了，想建个小东西时。
We're just exactly what he said, because it was overheard by one of her employees who was working late and told that story. He said, Mr. Hurst had a high voice so it carried. It was the end of the day and Mr. Hurst said, well, I was browsing through Los Angeles bookstores as I'm prone to do and I found these bungalow books and I saw one that I liked and he turned the page.
我们知道他确切说了什么，因为她的一位加班的员工无意中听到了，并讲述了这个故事。他说：“赫斯特先生嗓门很高，所以声音传得很远。”那是那天结束的时候，赫斯特先生说：“好吧，我像往常一样在洛杉矶的书店里浏览，我发现了一些平房书，我看到了一本我喜欢的。”然后他翻了一页。
It was labeled JAPO Swiss Bungalow. Walter Stauberg said he laughed at that and so did she. Walter Stauberg, he was an engineer and he was very involved in the early engineering, particularly at Sonsimi. So he would look up at and say, well, there's the JAPO Swiss Bungalow, it was going to be a modest six months, a single cottage, the over and no time. six months, a single cottage, the over and no time. And then Walter also said, but within a month we were going on the grand scale, and that's the scale at which W.R. Hurst operated. He met her down at the train station in San Luis Vistpo.
上面写着“日瑞式平房”（Japo-Swiss Bungalow）。沃尔特·斯托伯格（Walter Steilberg）说他听了笑了，她也笑了。沃尔特·斯托伯格是一位工程师，他非常深入地参与了早期的工程，特别是在圣西蒙（San Simeon）。所以他会抬头说：“好吧，这就是那个日瑞式平房。”这原本只是一个为期六个月的简易小屋，但很快就超出了预期。沃尔特还说：“但不到一个月，我们就开始大规模施工了。”这就是W·R·赫斯特运作的规模。他在圣路易斯奥比斯波（San Luis Obispo）的火车站接到了她。
Steve Zegar was a young man who had a tin lizzy and her said hired him. They were just the two of them, Dawn, tin lizzy had to drive what today is an hour almost and back then was certainly two or more. They drove through the Metropolis of Simeon, which back then when 1919 was two hotels and a couple of stores and I was pretty much it. They got to the end of the road where there's a Victorian ranch house and that was where the road stopped. Julia looked over and sitting at the end at the start of a dusty trail were two settled horses.
史蒂夫·泽加（Steve Zegar）是个年轻人，有一辆福特T型车（Tin Lizzie），赫斯特雇了他。他们只有两个人，黎明时分，T型车必须行驶一段今天需要近一小时、当时肯定要两小时以上的路程。他们穿过了圣西蒙的大都市，在1919年，那里只有两家旅馆和几家商店，基本就这些了。他们到达了路的尽头，那里有一座维多利亚式的牧场房子，路就在那里断了。朱莉娅看过去，在尘土飞扬的小径起点坐着两匹马。
She was 47. She was wearing, I'm sure, what she always wore. She had a very practical wardrobe for her work and it really was based on something. It was based on the French walking suit. It was an eminently practical thing, but not for horseback riding. And, and anyway, she looked at him, and she said, I, I don't know how to ride. And furthermore, I don't intend to learn. And, and W.R. had been going up that hill since he was two in 1865, his father bought that land. So what they did, Zegard saw these cowboys riding by and he called them over, first got
她当时47岁。我敢肯定她穿着她一贯的衣服。她为工作准备了非常实用的衣橱，这确实是有依据的。它是基于法式步行套装。那是一件非常实用的东西，但不适合骑马。总之，她看着他，说：“我不知道怎么骑马。而且，我也不打算学。”W·R从1865年两岁起就一直上那座山，那是他父亲买下的土地。所以他们做了什么呢？泽加看到牛仔们骑马经过，就把他们叫了过来，赫斯特先
on the horse, and Julia stayed in the taxi, in the back seat, and Zegard gunned the engine and drove it up the hill, 1600 foot elevation where rocks, beautiful, enormous rugged size, you know, burst out of the landscape, it's steep and it's far. The cowboys rode alongside. They roped the bumper and pulled the taxi over the really difficult spots if there was slippery grass or if he was having a hard time getting around there.
上了马，而朱莉娅坐在出租车的后座上，泽加猛踩油门，把车开上了山。海拔1600英尺，岩石美丽、巨大且崎岖，景观非常陡峭，路途遥远。牛仔们骑马并排而行。他们用绳子套住保险杠，在遇到湿滑的草地或难以通过的地方时，把出租车拉过去。
And that was her first trip to San Simian. J.M. wasn't just the architect, she was also the interior designer and the landscape architect and essentially the contractor for the entire job and made an astonishing 568 train trips from San Francisco down to San Simeon. Our schedule is completely exhausting. She would get on the train on Friday, take the train down to San Luis Obispo. She'd be notorious for working on the train.
那是她第一次去圣西蒙。朱莉娅·摩根不仅是建筑师，她还是室内设计师、景观设计师，本质上还是整个工程的承包商。她从旧金山到圣西蒙往返了惊人的568次火车。她的日程安排极其令人疲惫。她会在周五坐上火车，前往圣路易斯奥比斯波。她以在火车上工作而闻名。
She asked for an upper birth because she was, as you know, diminutive. She was about five foot two, I think, with the assistance of a hat. Maybe even five three with the assistance of a hat. That hat was important. She could sit upright and draw while the train was heading south. Eight hours one way and a two to two and a half hour drive from the train station in San Luis Obispo to San Simian. She would get a cab and she had a regular driver who would take her to San Simian, which to this day is still like a 45-minute drive from San Luis Obispo. The roads were smaller, the cars, the wheels, the tires were much smaller then.
她要求睡上铺，因为你知道，她身材娇小。我想她大约五英尺二英寸高，戴上帽子可能五英尺三英寸。那顶帽子很重要。火车向南行驶时，她可以坐直身体画图。单程八小时，从圣路易斯奥比斯波火车站到圣西蒙还要两到两个半小时的车程。她会叫一辆出租车，她有一位固定的司机带她去圣西蒙，即使在今天，从圣路易斯奥比斯波开车过去也要45分钟。当时的道路更窄，汽车的轮子和轮胎也小得多。
She wrote to her, it was one continuous skid. She said, if you want to break every bone in your worst enemy's body, treat them to the trip. After a bad rain. She would get there very late. She would spend the weekend at San Simeon. Workout, whatever issues needed to be worked out on site there. She'd spend the whole day Sunday and meet with her. WR generally came down one or two times a month. On Sunday night, you should do the whole thing in reverse. One of her draftsmen, he said,
她写信说，那是一路不停的打滑。她说：“如果你想把你最坏的敌人的每一根骨头都弄断，就请他们坐这趟车。”在大雨过后。她会很晚才到。她会在圣西蒙度过周末。在现场解决任何需要解决的问题。她会花整个周日与他会面。W·R通常每月来一两次。周日晚上，她会把整个过程反过来做一遍。她的一位绘图员说：
I went along with her and we got back to San Francisco on Monday morning and I was exhausted and she walked right into the office and went to work. And that's how she did it. Herst Castle, it was a very romantic place. It was the sight of a great love story between her and his companion, Mary and Davies. It was a love story about his childhood and his parents and California, and they shared that.
“我和她一起去，周一早上回到旧金山，我累坏了，而她直接走进办公室开始工作。”她就是这样做的。赫氏古堡是一个非常浪漫的地方。它是他和他的伴侣玛丽恩·戴维斯（Marion Davies）之间伟大爱情故事的发生地。这是一个关于他的童年、他的父母和加州的故事，他们共同分享了这一切。
And she was kind of the on-site color commentator. It might be two in the morning in New York and he's trying to get an addition out because that's when he worked. Is it newspaper man? He could send a telegram. Dear Miss Morgan, I've just bought some columns. Let's talk about where to put them at the ranch. And she could write to him about the beautiful sunsets or the alligator pairs, which is what they call avocado spec then, and how the sunset was blue beyond imagining. So, one of her employees said, she was the only person who never took advantage of him, who never wanted anything from him.
她是现场的色彩评论员。纽约可能已经是凌晨两点了，他正试图赶出一篇增刊，因为那是他工作的时间。作为一名报人，他可以发一封电报：“亲爱的摩根小姐，我刚买了一些柱子。我们谈谈把它们放在牧场的什么地方吧。”她可以写信告诉他美丽的日落，或者鳄梨（当时他们称之为“鳄梨梨”），以及日落是如何蓝得超乎想象。所以，她的一位员工说，她是唯一一个从不占他便宜、从不向他索取任何东西的人。
And he, of course, was completely and utterly respectful of her and supportive of her authority. This was a collaboration between two remarkable people. They had a long association, and in many ways I would even say a romantic one. It's long as it is clear that I'm talking about a platonic romance. You know, the romance of two, as Walter Stalberg, who was one of her top employees, said two long-distance dreamers. He watched them in the Refectory, which is, since in his dining room, 72 feet long and 28 feet high, and 27 feet wide.
而他，当然，对她完全且绝对地尊重，并支持她的权威。这是两个杰出人物之间的合作。他们有着长期的交往，在很多方面我甚至会说这是一种浪漫。只要明确我指的是柏拉图式的浪漫。你知道，正如她的一位顶级员工沃尔特·斯托伯格所说，这是两个“长途梦想家”的浪漫。他看着他们在餐厅里，那是圣西蒙的餐厅，长72英尺，高28英尺，宽27英尺。
He said, the rest of us could have been a million miles away. He was talking, and she was talking, and they were drawing, and he said, and you could almost see this bark. Travel from one to the other, they're foreheads. Because these two very different people just clicked. It was remarkable the closeness that they had. Julie Morgan's career was as dependent upon the California Women's movement as the
他说：“我们其他人可能在一百万英里之外。”他在说话，她在说话，他们在画图，他说：“你几乎可以看到这种火花在他们之间传递，在他们的额头之间。”因为这两个截然不同的人就是合拍。他们之间的亲密关系非常了不起。朱莉娅·摩根的职业生涯既依赖于加州妇女运动，也
California women's movement benefited from Julie Morgan. By the time Morgan came back to the United States, by the time she got back from Paris, California women were really gearing up into all sorts of organized activities. And her generation was leading the way. She was 30, her friends were in their 30s, they had time, money, and education to organize around all different things, suffrage, women in higher education, urban development, and beautification, juvenile delinquency. And so you end up with Julia Morgan designing a landscape for those women, this built evidence of a social history
受益于加州妇女运动。当摩根回到美国时，当她从巴黎回来时，加州女性正积极投身于各种有组织的活动中。她那一代人正引领着潮流。她30岁，她的朋友们也都在30多岁，她们有时间、金钱和教育背景来围绕各种议题组织活动：选举权、女性高等教育、城市发展与美化、青少年犯罪。所以你最终会看到朱莉娅·摩根为这些女性设计景观，这是20世纪初社会史和性别史的建筑证据。
and a gender history from the early 20th century. She had a lot of friends who were involved with the Young Women's Christian Association or the YWCA. YWCA's were essential and she literally built more than it doesn't. It was one of the most important organizations nationwide to create social educational, recreational and residential facilities, targeted towards young single women who were moving to the city for the first time to work. She mentored via her women's clubs and YWCA's, which were central to young women leaving their family farms and coming into cities to allow them to work but not have to live in
她有很多朋友参与了基督教女青年会（YWCA）。YWCA至关重要，她实际上建造了不止一打。它是全国最重要的组织之一，旨在为第一次搬到城市工作、年轻的单身女性创造社会、教育、娱乐和居住设施。她通过她的妇女俱乐部和YWCA进行指导，这些设施对于离开家庭农场进入城市的年轻女性来说至关重要，使她们能够工作，而不必住在
an unsafe, reborning house full of traveling salesmen or be in unsafe conditions. There was this moral control, social control element to the YWCA combined with the growth of women's opportunities outside of the home to earn money and independence, at least before marriage. San Luis Obispo, San Luis Obispo, the best city that I know. I'm Vicki Carroll, and I'm the president of the Monday Club and the Monday Club House Conservancy in San Luis Obispo. I'm Jennifer Alderman.
充满旅行推销员的不安全、肮脏的房子里，或处于不安全的环境中。YWCA有一种道德控制、社会控制的元素，结合了女性在家庭之外获得金钱和独立机会的增长，至少在结婚前是这样。圣路易斯奥比斯波，圣路易斯奥比斯波，我所知道的最好的城市。我是维基·卡罗尔（Vicki Carroll），我是圣路易斯奥比斯波“周一俱乐部”（Monday Club）和“周一俱乐部会所保护协会”的主席。我是詹妮弗·奥尔德曼（Jennifer Alderman）。
I am the treasurer of the Monday Club and the Monday Club House Conservancy and also a past president. It is a joy and organ design building built by the women who own the Monday Club. She would do whatever was best for the club and whatever the club could afford. And the club could afford a lot more because she often took no profit whatsoever and donated her services. And that's what she did at the Monday Club in San Luis Pespo. The president at the time lived next door to Mr. Zegar who was the taxi driver who would pick Miss Morgan up
我是周一俱乐部和周一俱乐部会所保护协会的财务主管，也是前任主席。朱莉娅·摩根设计的建筑是由拥有周一俱乐部的女性建造的。她会做对俱乐部最有利的事情，以及俱乐部负担得起的事情。俱乐部能负担得起更多，因为她经常不收任何利润，并捐赠了她的服务。这就是她在圣路易斯奥比斯波的周一俱乐部所做的事情。当时的主席住在泽加先生隔壁，他就是那位接送摩根小姐的司机，
in San Luis Obispo and take her to the castle. So our president at the time asked Mr. Zegar if he would speak with Julia about perhaps designing a clubhouse for us. And she agreed to do that and had communications with the club members and settled on a fee of $800. And then she decided that if the members of the Monday club
在圣路易斯奥比斯波接她去古堡。所以我们当时的主席问泽加先生，是否可以和朱莉娅谈谈为我们设计会所的事。她同意了，并与俱乐部成员进行了沟通，最终确定了800美元的费用。然后她决定，如果周一俱乐部的成员
would house her when she came into town, because if you think back to those times in late 20s, it wasn't really proper for a woman to stay in a hotel by herself. So our Monday Club members, Houseness Morgan, before she went to the castle the next day. She'd arrive on the train, so she'd have to spend the night, and she waved the $800 fee.
能在她进城时为她提供住宿，因为如果你回想那个时代，在20世纪20年代末，女性独自住在旅馆里并不太合适。所以我们的周一俱乐部成员在摩根小姐第二天去古堡之前接待了她。她坐火车到达，所以她必须过夜，于是她免除了800美元的费用。
Our membership at one time was over 300, so we have photos of this room packed of gills. This social space was used a lot because there really wasn't an opportunity for people to go out and socialize other than in bars or, you know, San Luis Vispos was still relatively small. So they would hold concerts here, plays from the photos that looks like they had a lot of fun. from the photos that it looks like they had a lot of fun. This historic building designed by renowned architect Julien Morgan, first opened his doors to the Chinese Young Women's Christa Association YWCA in 1932. My name is Justin Hoover, I'm the executive director of the Chinese Historical Society of America
我们的会员人数一度超过300人，所以我们有这个房间挤满人的照片。这个社交空间被大量使用，因为除了酒吧之外，人们确实没有机会出去社交，或者说，圣路易斯奥比斯波当时仍然相对较小。所以他们会在这里举办音乐会、戏剧，从照片上看，他们似乎玩得很开心。这座由著名建筑师朱莉娅·摩根设计的历史建筑，于1932年首次向中国基督教女青年会（YWCA）敞开大门。我叫贾斯汀·胡佛（Justin Hoover），我是美国华人历史学会的执行董事，
in Tears of Scope. We were founded in 1963 as a society dedicated to telling the stories of the Chinese in America. During the 30s, we were still in the exclusionary period. So in 1882 was the exclusion act. And what that meant was the Chinese weren't allowed in the United States unless they were doing certain vocations and professions. During that period, you get this goal for the Chinese in America to fit in. And to do that, the Chinese adapted a kind of hybrid model of life, whether you get these Chinatowns that look Chinese-y,
在旧金山。我们成立于1963年，是一个致力于讲述美国华人故事的协会。在30年代，我们仍处于排华时期。1882年是《排华法案》。这意味着华人除非从事某些特定的职业，否则不允许进入美国。在那段时期，美国华人有一个融入的目标。为了做到这一点，华人采用了一种混合的生活模式，你会看到这些看起来“中式”的唐人街，
and I'm going to use that word, you know, because it's got a cliche of Chinese, that maybe hearkens back to the homeland or to architectural details that are commonly understood and recognized as Chinese, maybe divorcing them from the significance of the original facade or edifice or structure on which they were used. The use of architectural detail in that way, today we see that as a sense of orientalism, but the time is a way for people of the Chinese culture to share their culture with Westerners in America, and in that way find a place where they could hybrid share their culture with Westerners in America and in that way find a place where they could hybridize their culture and be accepted and not fear persecution. The Chinese in America were scared at the time and they still are in many ways today. They're still facing violence against
我要用这个词，因为这带有对中国文化的刻板印象，也许让人回想起祖国，或者回想起通常被理解和认可为中国的建筑细节，也许将它们与它们所使用的原始立面、建筑或结构的意义分离开来。以这种方式使用建筑细节，今天我们将其视为一种“东方主义”，但在当时，这是华人分享文化、寻找一个可以融合文化并被接受而不必担心迫害的地方的一种方式。当时的美国华人很害怕，今天在很多方面依然如此。他们仍然面临针对
Chinese and Asians. The space originally was a YWCA. In the 30s when it was built there were not a lot of places where women in San Francisco, especially Chinese women, could feel comfortable. And so the space was designed as a residency and a physical location for community and gathering. People could learn English, they could dance, they could have exercise, they could have community. How to imagine it would be a bustling place. Be a place that's safe for women. I think there would be a lot of fun at being here. I like to hope that you'd hear a lot of noises of people laughing and having a good time.
华人及亚裔的暴力。这个空间最初是YWCA。在30年代它建成时，旧金山并没有多少地方能让女性，尤其是华人女性感到舒适。因此，这个空间被设计为一个居住地和社区聚会的物理场所。人们可以学习英语、跳舞、锻炼、建立社区。很难想象它曾经是一个熙熙攘攘的地方。一个对女性来说安全的地方。我想在这里会有很多乐趣。我希望你能听到人们欢笑和享受美好时光的声音。
She closed down her office when she was losing clients and slipping into ill health, and then she just lived largely alone in her apartment in Oakland. There are few people who are still alive that knew her personally and said she just lived this quiet life and then kind of slipped out of it. She retired in 1951, but then she didn't die until 1957. I think a combination of the Great Depression and the war, which really set back the architecture industry for a significant amount of time, Then the stylistic changes post-war, there comes a point in the leading edge of American architecture where everyone wants it to be about modern forms,
她在失去客户、健康状况下滑时关闭了办公室，然后大部分时间独自住在奥克兰的公寓里。现在几乎没有人还活着能亲自认识她，他们说她只是过着平静的生活，然后悄然离去。她于1951年退休，但直到1957年才去世。我认为大萧条和战争的结合，确实让建筑行业停滞了很长一段时间，然后是战后的风格变化，美国建筑的前沿出现了一个转折点，每个人都希望它是关于现代形式的，
casting off the old, stripping out the ornament, and that was not something that Julia Morgan ever really did. And then her own ill health meant that she spent the last two decades of her life slipping from the center of architecture. When she died, you know, it was written up in the San Francisco Examiner, like she was known in her city, but it wasn't like her work was in the air, wasn't like people were writing about it as if it was exciting, the new interest had shifted elsewhere. There was this whole feminist architecture history moment in the 70s and early 80s that I think Morgan benefited from, then like many things when kind
抛弃旧事物，剥离装饰，而这并不是朱莉娅·摩根真正做过的事情。她自己的健康状况不佳意味着她生命的最后二十年逐渐淡出了建筑中心。她去世时，你知道，旧金山的报纸上写了报道，她在她的城市里很有名，但她的作品并没有引起轰动，人们并没有像谈论令人兴奋的新事物那样谈论它，兴趣已经转移到别处了。在70年代和80年代初，确实出现过一阵女性建筑史的热潮，我认为摩根从中受益，然后像许多事情一样，有一段时间变得
of out of fashion for a while, and I think it's coming back now. So it's interesting to look at Morgan as the beneficiary of this early uprising of women's power that then goes underground, particularly in the postwar era, and then rises again in the 70s. And so the times in which people are interested in Morgan also go along with the times in which there's a new interest in women and power and expanding the canon in architecture history. There's a really famous exhibition that was held at the Brooklyn Museum during this time and I think that was the first time people said, oh wait a second, where are the women architects? Yes, we're trying to increase the number of women in architecture now, but it's really helpful to know
不那么流行了，我想现在它又回来了。所以，将摩根视为这种早期女性力量崛起的受益者是很有趣的，这种力量在战后时期转入地下，然后在70年代再次兴起。因此，人们对摩根感兴趣的时期，也与人们对女性和权力以及扩展建筑史经典的新兴趣相吻合。当时在布鲁克林博物馆举办了一个非常著名的展览，我想那是人们第一次说：“哦，等一下，女建筑师在哪里？”是的，我们现在正试图增加建筑领域的女性人数，但了解
that there are founding mothers. Let's go find them. Let's go look for their history. We're around here on KNBR68. Now, I really want to talk with Sarah Boutel. I mean, I want to talk with her so bad that if we can't make a connection here, I'm just going to send a limo for you.
有“创始母亲”的存在真的很有帮助。让我们去寻找她们。让我们去寻找她们的历史。我们现在在KNBR68电台。现在，我真的很想和莎拉·布特尔（Sarah Boutelle）谈谈。我的意思是，我太想和她谈谈了，如果我们在这里联系不上，我就直接派辆豪华轿车去接你。
Hello, Sarah. I'm right here. Oh, good. I'm so glad. Sarah, Boutel, has written a book as we just mentioned, if you just turn on the radio. Julia Morgan, architect. It's a beautiful, beautiful, there was not very much material. And of course, Sarah Holmes, Boutel, really was indefaticable. You know, she worked 14 years on her biography, Julia Morgan Architect. She was a one woman marching band. She'd been, and she was in her middle 60s. So she had kind of Julia Morgan rate energy.
你好，莎拉。我就在这里。哦，太好了。我很高兴。莎拉·布特尔写了一本书，正如我们刚才提到的，如果你刚打开收音机的话，《朱莉娅·摩根，建筑师》。这是一本非常非常美的书，当时并没有太多资料。当然，莎拉·霍姆斯·布特尔（Sarah Holmes Boutelle）确实是不知疲倦的。你知道，她在传记《朱莉娅·摩根，建筑师》上工作了14年。她是一个人的行军乐队。她当时已经60多岁了。所以她有一种朱莉娅·摩根式的能量。
How did your fascination with Julia Morgan began, Sarah? It began as it does with many people. When I went to the first castle, I had no idea that it was so beautiful and then I discovered it was by a woman's architect and I went everywhere trying to find a book about her, some material about her. And since there wasn't any, finally it struck me that I had to parrot it out on my own, finding the buildings and finding the information about Julia Morgan. I've been on the job for 14 years, it's like a long time to do any one thing.
莎拉，你对朱莉娅·摩根的迷恋是如何开始的？它和许多人一样，是从我第一次去赫氏古堡开始的。我当时根本不知道它这么美，然后我发现它是一位女建筑师的作品，我到处寻找关于她的书，关于她的一些资料。由于根本没有，最后我意识到我必须自己去挖掘，寻找建筑，寻找关于朱莉娅·摩根的信息。我从事这项工作已经14年了，做任何事情这么久都是很长的时间。
But it was great from the whole time because it was partly like detective work. She went around, she knocked on doors to find clients. She got in touch with the family. She went to organizations. She did a tremendous amount of work. She devoted her life to it, $30,000 of her own money, tremendous amount of effort on her behalf,
但整个过程都很棒，因为它有点像侦探工作。她四处奔走，敲门寻找客户。她与家人取得联系。她去了各个组织。她做了大量的工作。她为此奉献了毕生精力，自掏腰包3万美元，为她付出了巨大的努力，
and it's created the way for other people to latch on like I did. Her work was very successful while she was working, but then at the period just a little bit before her death, the modernist or international style took over and her work along with out of many other California architects was in the shade so that it wasn't only her efforts to remain private but people's lack of interest in California architecture that is made her unknown. The fight for getting Julia Morgan the recognition she deserves.
这为其他人像我一样加入进来铺平了道路。她的作品在她工作时非常成功，但在她去世前不久，现代主义或国际风格占据了主导地位，她的作品和其他许多加州建筑师的作品一样被遮蔽了，所以不仅是她保持低调的努力，还有人们对加州建筑缺乏兴趣，才使她变得默默无闻。为朱莉娅·摩根争取她应得的认可的斗争。
After this. Here again is Finding Julia Morgan from New Angle Voice. Would you believe that is recently is 1978 when we were discussing the Equal Rights Amendment that the President of the AIA declared to the press that he would never hire a woman architect? the press that he would never hire a woman architect. On behalf of these women practitioners, I express our collective and respectful anger. I had met Beverly Willis in 2009 at the first women's leadership summit in Chicago. She had given a presentation and said, why can't the AI give a gold medal to a woman? I remember thinking, well that's silly, you know, you don't just give a gold medal to a
广告之后。这里依然是《新视角之声》的《寻找朱莉娅·摩根》。你能相信吗？就在1978年，当我们讨论《平等权利修正案》时，美国建筑师协会（AIA）的主席竟然向媒体宣称，他永远不会雇佣女建筑师？代表这些女性从业者，我表达我们集体且尊重的愤怒。我是在2009年芝加哥举行的第一届女性领导力峰会上见到贝弗利·威利斯的。她做了一个演讲，说：“为什么AIA不能给女性颁发金奖？”我记得当时想：“嗯，那太傻了，你知道，你不能只是给一个……”
person. They earn a gold medal. It's a process, I'm sure. Then a couple years in 2012, I'm sitting and watching, and there's three men there, and I'm like, oh, this is how you do it. This is the room where they vote on the gold medal, I'm sitting and watching, and there's three men there. And I'm like, oh, this is how you do it. This is the room where they vote on the gold medal. I'm like, well, who gets to nominate you to be one of those three people? It's not like a lottery thing. You say, dear God, give me a gold medal.
人。他们赢得了金牌。我相信这是一个过程。后来在2012年，我坐在那里观看，有三个人在那里，我想，哦，原来是这样。这就是他们投票决定金牌的房间，我坐在那里观看，有三个人在那里。我想，哦，原来是这样。这就是他们投票决定金牌的房间。我想，好吧，谁有权提名你成为那三个人之一？这又不是抽奖。你说，亲爱的上帝，请给我一枚金牌。
Give me a gold medal. And God says, if you want to win the lottery, you have to buy a ticket. So I sat there and said, well, how do you buy a ticket to be one of those three people? You have to make a portfolio. And you have to submit the portfolio and the portfolio has to demonstrate a body of work that's of significant stature to be worthy of the gold medal. So how do you do that?
给我一枚金牌。上帝说，如果你想中彩票，你得先买张彩票。所以我坐在那里说，好吧，怎么才能买到成为那三个人之一的彩票呢？你必须制作一份作品集。你必须提交这份作品集，而且作品集必须展示出具有足够分量的作品，才配得上金牌。那么该怎么做呢？
You look at the guy who's winning this year and say, how can I find a woman who has a portfolio like that? I started scouring all the's winning this year and say, how can I find a woman who has a portfolio like that? I started scouring all the books. I sat there and I read. I was like, I can nominate someone and I was like, who could I nominate? I spent two weeks going through this process of calling on my friends and saying, who could we nominate? I would say, what about this person?
你看看今年获奖的那个人，然后说，我怎么才能找到一个拥有这样作品集的女性呢？我开始搜寻所有的书。我坐在那里阅读。我想，我可以提名某人，我在想，我可以提名谁呢？我花了两个星期的时间，打电话给我的朋友们，问他们，我们可以提名谁？我会说，这个人怎么样？
And they'd say, too young. They'll get it someday. You know, or what about this person? No, not enough work, or whatever. So then I just sat down with some books of women architects, and I started going through them. The only one that had a portfolio that was significant enough was Julia Morgan.
他们会说，太年轻了。总有一天她会得到的。你知道，或者这个人怎么样？不，作品不够多，或者诸如此类的理由。所以我只是坐下来，翻看了一些女性建筑师的书，开始仔细阅读。唯一一个作品集分量足够重的人是朱莉娅·摩根。
I said, well, I'll just call up Haleighn, combed Striling, who's president, and her first week in office, I called her up and said, can I bring Julia Morgan forward for the AI gold medal? She wrote back and said, well, that would be fabulous. And I never knew anything about her until this. And I told my daughter for the next six months, she could sit at the kitchen table and do her homework While I would sit at the dining table and do my homework, and that was what we would be doing.
我说，好吧，我就给海伦·康布·斯特林打电话，她是主席，在她上任的第一周，我给她打了电话，说，我可以提名朱莉娅·摩根获得美国建筑师协会（AIA）金牌吗？她回信说，那太棒了。在此之前我对她一无所知。接下来的六个月里，我告诉我的女儿，她可以在餐桌旁做作业，而我坐在餐桌旁做我的功课，这就是我们要做的。
We spent everything from January until June when I got this portfolio done. I went to work, but I came home at night and that's all I did was Julie Morgan. I just brought her up in every conversation. Oh, we're talking about disaster. Oh, did you know that Julia Morgan saved the city of San Francisco from a total disaster by knowing about reinforce concrete? Oh, did you see the watercol is so-and-so did? Did you know that Julia Morgan was an excellent water colorist? She learned that at the cold of Bazar's because none of the guys would work with her answer.
从一月到六月，我完成了这份作品集。我去上班，但晚上回家后，我所做的一切就是研究朱莉娅·摩根。我在每一次谈话中都会提到她。哦，我们在谈论灾难。哦，你知道朱莉娅·摩根通过了解钢筋混凝土拯救了旧金山吗？哦，你看到某某人的水彩画了吗？你知道朱莉娅·摩根是一位出色的水彩画家吗？她在巴黎美术学院学到了这一点，因为当时没有男人愿意和她一起工作。
She went off into the landscape and drew things like Monet. When I finally left the board, I remember Bruce Sucanix said to me, when are you going to stop talking about Julia Morgan? I said, I will stop talking about Julia Morgan. I tried to bring her in every conversation. I will stop talking about her when you talk about her more than I do. You know, so I try to bring her into every conversation
她走进风景中，画出了像莫奈那样的作品。当我最终离开董事会时，我记得布鲁斯·苏卡尼克斯对我说，你什么时候才能停止谈论朱莉娅·摩根？我说，我会停止谈论朱莉娅·摩根的。我试图在每一次谈话中都提到她。当你谈论她的次数比我多时，我就不再谈论她了。你知道，所以我尽量在每一次谈话中都提到她。
in that sort of way to really just open the mental thinking. And I really worked the room. And I understood that I need to have really nice letters from really important people. We wrote to Maria Schriver and asked her to write a letter and she agreed. Senator Feinstein, she lives across the street from a Julia Morgan building. At a time when there were few women in the professional world, when we weren't even allowed to vote, Julia was a real trailblazer.
以那种方式真正打开思维。我确实在那个房间里做了很多工作。我明白我需要得到真正重要人物的非常好的推荐信。我们写信给玛丽亚·施莱弗，请她写一封信，她同意了。黛安·范斯坦参议员，她就住在朱莉娅·摩根建筑的街对面。在那个专业领域女性很少、我们甚至还不被允许投票的时代，朱莉娅是一位真正的开拓者。
I went to see Mike Braves. He said, oh yes, sir, I'll help you. I got Frank Gary as well, because Maria Shriver turns out she has this very strong relationship with him and she can calm him up and say, Frank, why don't you help with this? She paved the path, not just for women architects, but for all women.
我去找了迈克·格雷夫斯。他说，哦，是的，我会帮你的。我还找了弗兰克·盖里，因为玛丽亚·施莱弗和他的关系非常密切，她可以打电话给他，说，弗兰克，你为什么不帮帮这个忙呢？她不仅为女性建筑师，也为所有女性铺平了道路。
She faced many challenges in the male dominated architecture industry. She is a living proof that no matter the obstacles, no matter the status quo, you can achieve greatness. The portfolio goes to this jury. I was waiting at home and saying, well, maybe she'll get it, but we'll probably have to do it a couple times, but we'll see what happens. And then I got this beautiful letter that says you have been selected for the short list. So then I was like, what do we have to do?
她在男性主导的建筑行业面临许多挑战。她是活生生的证明，无论遇到什么障碍，无论现状如何，你都能取得伟大成就。作品集交给了评审团。我在家里等着，心想，也许她会得到它，但我们可能得做几次，看看会发生什么。然后我收到了一封漂亮的信，说你已经被选入候选名单了。所以我当时想，我们必须做什么？
We have to do another presentation in front of the board. I ended up asking Jeannie Gang to do the presentation. I said, this will be training for you to get your gold medal. And she wrote back and says, I'm going to take this really seriously and I want to do a good job. The room had started following like dominoes. People were saying this for this, this for this guy, supportive statements for all these other ones. And gradually it became more and more for Julia Morgan.
我们必须在董事会面前再做一次陈述。我最终请珍妮·甘来做陈述。我说，这对你获得金牌将是一种训练。她回信说，我会非常认真地对待这件事，我想把它做好。房间里的人开始像多米诺骨牌一样跟进。人们开始说支持这个，支持那个家伙，对所有其他人发表支持声明。渐渐地，支持朱莉娅·摩根的声音越来越多。
The votes were cast on secret paper ballots and then they were taken into a back room and counted and then we are all sitting there. First they told us who won and then they brought the guests back in. So, Jeannie Gang is sitting there and I can't restrain myself so I walked over to her and I just, I didn't tell her what had happened but I just gave her this huge, how I'm going to have this huge smile on my face and tears were coming down my face. I was so excited about her getting the FAAIA. I think I was more excited about that. It's a very, very quiet ceremony. They have to get everyone across the stage,
投票是在秘密纸质选票上进行的，然后被带到后台房间计票，然后我们都坐在那里。他们先告诉我们谁赢了，然后把客人们带回来。所以，珍妮·甘坐在那里，我无法抑制自己，所以我走到她身边，我没有告诉她发生了什么，但我给了她一个巨大的拥抱，我脸上带着灿烂的笑容，眼泪顺着我的脸流下来。我为她获得美国建筑师协会荣誉会员（FAIA）感到非常兴奋。我想我对此感到更加兴奋。这是一个非常非常安静的仪式。他们必须让每个人都走上舞台，
to get their medal and get their handshakes and stuff. So they say, please hold all the applause till the very end. And then they came to Julia Morgan and the whole room erupted in the standing ovation. That's when I really, truly cried, because I was just like, well, this really means something. It's not just that we finally have a woman whose name is going to be carved and granite,
领取奖牌和握手之类的。所以他们说，请在最后之前保持所有掌声。然后他们提到了朱莉娅·摩根，整个房间爆发出了起立鼓掌。那时我才真正地哭了，因为我当时想，好吧，这真的意味着什么。这不仅仅是我们终于有了一位名字将被刻在花岗岩上的女性，
that we're finally shattering the glass ceiling and getting recognition for all types of people. The whole room recognized it. It was just a beautiful moment. We are very proud to posthumously award the AI Gold Medal to Julia Morgan, FAAI, the early 20th century architect whose copious output of quality work secured her position as the first great female American architect. All the little quotes that we have of her they've all been ingrained in my brain now. I've learned for myself to now pursue things in a more dogged way the way she does. Just pursue excellence in everything that I do.
我们终于打破了玻璃天花板，并获得了各界人士的认可。整个房间都意识到了这一点。那真是一个美好的时刻。我们非常自豪地将美国建筑师协会金牌追授给朱莉娅·摩根，她是20世纪初的建筑师，她大量的高质量作品确保了她作为第一位伟大的美国女性建筑师的地位。我们拥有的关于她的所有小语录现在都已经铭刻在我的脑海里了。我已经学会了像她一样以更顽强的方式去追求事物。在我的每一件事中都追求卓越。
The form that she filled out for the AIA membership in 1946, the form said the architect will list what he has done. And she circled the he and wrote a giant exclamation point over it. She's really been a guidepost for me that she could have an engineer way of thinking and also be an exceptional Bozar at Sarketakt and live in a modern age and use glass and steel and light and form and really embrace all the things that were changing around her and the social changes that were happening for women and families and how we interact in the world. She must have been so tough to make it through her attempts to get into the Eccluboz Arts, to make it through the Ecclidobozarts to launch her own business in California
她在1946年填写的美国建筑师协会会员表格上，表格写着建筑师将列出他所做的事情。她圈出了“他”，并在上面写了一个巨大的感叹号。她确实一直是我的指路明灯，她可以拥有工程师的思维方式，同时也是一位杰出的巴黎美术学院建筑师，生活在现代，使用玻璃、钢铁、光线和形式，真正拥抱她周围正在发生的所有变化，以及为女性和家庭正在发生的社会变化，以及我们如何在世界上互动。她一定非常坚强，才能通过进入巴黎美术学院的尝试，才能通过巴黎美术学院，才能在加利福尼亚创办自己的企业，
when so few women own their own businesses. So I just see that toughness carrying through and I don't think she could have been as successful as she was if she wasn't really, really focused on doing the work. Special thanks in this episode to Alexandra Lang, Julia Donahoe, Karen McNeil, Victoria Casner, the Women of the Bunday Club of San Luis Obispo, Karen Fini at Mills College,
在那个很少有女性拥有自己企业的时代。所以我看到了那种坚韧不拔的精神，我不认为如果她不是真的非常非常专注于工作，她能取得如此大的成功。特别感谢本集中的亚历山德拉·朗、朱莉娅·多纳霍、凯伦·麦克尼尔、维多利亚·卡斯纳、圣路易斯奥比斯波邦代俱乐部的女性们、米尔斯学院的凯伦·菲尼，
and Justin Hoover at the Chinese Historical Society of America. The archival audio of Sarah Holmes-Buntel is from her Julia Morgan collection at Cal Poly University, San Luis Obispo, Special Collections and Archives. To learn more about the life and work of Julia Morgan, you can visit our website, vwaf.org,
以及美国华人历史学会的贾斯汀·胡佛。莎拉·福尔摩斯·邦特尔的档案音频来自她在加州理工州立大学圣路易斯奥比斯波分校特别收藏与档案馆的朱莉娅·摩根收藏。要了解更多关于朱莉娅·摩根的生活和工作，您可以访问我们的网站 vwaf.org，
where you will find a rich collection of archival material from her career and read extended interviews with additional Julien Morgan scholars not heard in this episode. New Angle Voice is brought to you by the Beverly Willis Architecture Foundation and produced by Brandy Hell. Our editorial advisor is Alexandra Lang and research is provided by Ashlyn McNamara. I'm your host, Cynthia Crackauer. I'm so excited about this podcast. Few things have made me as delighted as listening to the first episode of new angle voice. Go subscribe right now.
在那里您将找到她职业生涯中丰富的档案材料，并阅读本集中未提及的其他朱莉娅·摩根学者的深度访谈。New Angle Voice 由贝弗利·威利斯建筑基金会为您呈现，由布兰迪·霍尔制作。我们的编辑顾问是亚历山德拉·朗，研究由阿什琳·麦克纳马拉提供。我是主持人辛西娅·克拉考尔。我对这个播客感到非常兴奋。很少有事情能像听 New Angle Voice 的第一集那样让我感到高兴。现在就去订阅吧。
99% of visible is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, Swan Rihall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Boshamadon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Or on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI
99% Invisible 的成员包括德莱尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、斯旺·里霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、博沙马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，向北六个街区处的潘多拉大厦。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99PIorg。或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。您可以找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目，
at 99PI.org. Duh-uh to Stitch. Duh-uh to Stitch. Duh-uh to Stitch. Duh-uh to Stitcher. Serious exam. Don't out the stitch, don't out the stitch, don't out the stitch, don't out the churrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99PI.org。Stitcher。Stitcher。Stitcher。Stitcher。Sirius XM。Stitcher。Stitcher。Stitcher。Stitcher。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。